les ong sont devenus en 50 ans des
acteurs incontournables de la société
moderne par leur impact auprès des
gouvernements et du public confondant
régulièrement les grands principes avec
leurs objectifs politiques
ce sont des organisations non
gouvernementales mais pas des
organisations nos politiques les ong
développent des stratégies d' influence
qui privilégie l'émotionnel sur le ratio
le sectarisme de la majorité d'entre
elles les amènent à des interprétations
qui exclut toute pensée ou comportements
n'allant pas dans leur sens et leur
condition n'hésitant pas à tordre les
faits et utiliser tous les moyens pour
imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts ni sur la bbc insu réalité et
hopitalisé il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane et en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur est la
couleur seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée
n'oubliez pas de réagir sur le conte
télégramme verte et france vous pouvez
prendre part au débat interpellé nos
invités au sommaire de ce jeudi 28
octobre les tensions entre paris et
londres sur la question de la pêche qui
ne retombe pas le royaume uni vient de
convoquer l'ambassadrice de france
pourtant un peu plus tôt dans la journée
jean cassette se disait prêt à disputer
une main tendue par le premier ministre
au lendemain de l'annoncé de sanctions
pour pousser londres a accordé des
licences supplémentaires à ses pêcheurs
français ont cas de refus les bateaux
britanniques ne pourront plus débarquer
leur cargaison dans les ports français
les mesure jugée disproportionnée par
londres alors pari est il vraiment les
moyens de faire plier le royaume uni on
attend vos questions sur le compte des
graves verte et france
le royaume-uni précisément où se tient
en ce moment le procès en appel de
julian assange les etats-unis espèrent
convaincre la haute cour d'extrader le
fondateur de wikileaks la défense de
julian assange a insisté aujourd'hui sur
le risque de suicide du lanceur d alerte
en cas de retour forcé à washington les
américains sur eux que ce risque
n'existe pas on retrouvera notre envoyé
spécial katia pique nique sur place
[Musique]
le chômage at-il vraiment baissé en
france comme s'en félicite la ministre
du travail les abeilles bornes parle
d'un record depuis 20 ans pour les
embauches au troisième trimestre et fait
selon elle du quoi qu'il en coûte une
interprétation nuancée par certains
syndicats notamment la cgt qui parle de
chômeurs qui ne travaillait pas du tout
et qui auront juste retrouver des
contrats précaires ont des mènera le
vrai du faux dès 21h
toujours au chapitre économique les
salaires et le pouvoir d'achat au coeur
de la campagne présidentielle à l'heure
où l'infection s'attaque au porte
monnaie des français la plupart des
candidats s'empare du sujet hausse du
smic à gauche baisse de la fiscalité à
droite pourtant le gouvernement affirme
que le nouveau le niveau de vie à des
français a progressé depuis l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macron alors qu'il vivrait et
quelles solutions sur tout élément de
réponse tout à l'heure avec l'économiste
jacques sapir
[Musique]
après des jours à contre-courant la
france et le royaume uni tentent de
calmer le jeu paris veut bien discuter
si l'on ne respecte ses engagements sur
les quotas de pêche dans les eaux
britanniques
une main tendue que ne semble pas saisir
le royaume uni qui annonce ce soir qu'il
va convoqué l'ambassadrice de france
réactions au lendemain de l'annoncé de
mesures de rétorsion de paris des
sanctions qui pourraient être appliquées
dès mardi prochain si les pêcheurs
français n'obtenait pas de licence
supplémentaire solène goda
les autorités britanniques lâche du lest
jersey dépendance de la couronne a
annoncé la délivrance d'une vingtaine de
licences de pêche supplémentaires aux
bateaux français la petite île anglo
saxonne a cédé sous la pression ce mardi
elle la france a décidé d'appliquer des
mesures de rétorsion à l'égard des
importations maritime britannique dès le
2 novembre si le royaume uni ne
respectait pas l'accord post break site
une décision très critiquée par londres
il est très décevant de voir les
commentaires émis par la frontière nous
pensons qu'ils sont décevant et
disproportionnée et ne correspondent pas
ce que nous attendons d'un allié
partenaires proches
les mesures dont on nous menace ne
semble pas être compatible avec l'accord
de commerce et coopération ni avec le
droit international au sens large et si
elles sont appliquées elles feront
l'objet d'une réponse appropriée et
calibrés jean castex se dit ouvert aux
discussions tout en assumant la fermeté
de son gouvernement les britanniques
doivent respecter leurs engagements
comprenez que nous soyons intransigeant
sur le fait que les engagements pris par
nos pêcheurs soient tenus je ne demande
pas mieux qu une désescalade
interviennent le gouvernement de londres
à toutes les clés pour la réaliser nous
sommes ouvert en permanence aux
discussions matin midi et soir je veux
dire au gouvernement britannique que
nous veillerons respect de nos intérêts
et au respect de la parole donnée la
france renforce d'ores et déjà ses
contrôles dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi deux navires de pêche anglais ont
été verbalisés par la gendarmerie
maritime française dans la manche
de leur côté les pêcheurs français
souhaitent que le gouvernement garde le
cap ça fait plaisir d'entendre ça quoi
en espérant qu'on laisse pas notre
culotte et trouva jusqu'au bout on est
vraiment à quai pour certains bateaux il
ya certains bateaux des bateaux tout
récent et houda flac et qui peuvent pas
aller dans les dents les autres jersey
city bon port si vous leur entreprise et
revenir en difficulté le royaume uni n'a
pas encore accordé toutes les licences
négocié avec la france dans l'accord
post break site des dizaines de pêcheurs
français n'ont pas accès aux eaux
britanniques depuis plusieurs mois
certains professionnels du secteur
évoquent même une perte d'exploitation
de plus de 50% depuis le mois d'avril
très justement donne la parole ce soir à
ses pêcheurs français avec nous marc
delas et directeur du comité régional
des pêches de normandie bonsoir monsieur
données merci d'être avec nous tout
d'abord en est pas un politicien mais
quand même votre avis sur cette question
on voit que le bras de fer ce temps avec
la convocation de l'ambassadrice
française
ça vous inquiète que ça tourne ainsi à
la crise diplomatique ou finalement
autant crever l'abcès et elles ont aussi
pour les négociations
je crois qu'il est temps de crever
l'abcès nous sommes dans l'attenté et
l'incertitude eux uniquement pour la
question des accès dans les eaux
britanniques et jersiaise égard nos
sièges on attend ça depuis maintenant
onze mois et
les temps effectivement de
crever cet abcès bon après on sait très
bien que de la gesticulation de part et
d'autre chacun montre tout de suite ses
muscles je pense pas que ça finira en
bataille navale entre les britanniques
et les français nous sommes tout à fait
conscients que l'autre poids économique
dans les deux pays d'ailleurs est à
c'est assez petit par contre c'est clair
comme nous sommes des symboles et c'est
clair aussi que quelque part on
représente la façon dont l'accord du
bric site sera appliquée sur l'ensemble
des secteurs en tout cas la france a
brandi des menaces à l a montré ses
muscles
elle a une raison selon vous justement
d'utiliser deux de ces mesures de
rétorsion ces menaces en tout cas
alors lis les
menaces ou les mesures de comment dire
de mauvaise humeur pour reprendre
l'expression de la ministre
samedi dernier c'est oui c'était
peut-être un peu nécessaire pour faire
avancer les choses cela fait concernant
les britanniques donc le sud angleterre
est en fait il ya deux façades ya bien
la façade sud anglaise et la façade des
îles anglo normandes 1 concernant la le
sud angleterre
ça fait des mois maintenant que les
discussions se sont enlisées pendant
longtemps le royaume uni n'a pas répondu
aux demandes de l'europe sur qu'est-ce
qu'un avis remplaçant sans rentrer dans
le
dans le détail qui est d'une complexité
technique absolument ahurissante en gros
il ya des bateaux qui ont pu prouver
qu'ils étaient dans les eaux anglaises
de 2012 à 2016 par des moyens notamment
de repérage satellite mais entre 2016 et
2020 la vie s'est poursuivie certains
ont acheté ou ont fait construire des
bateaux et ils se retrouvent sans droits
mais alors qu'ils pratiquaient ces eaux
par le passé et leur seule façon de
rentrer et de faire un moment donné un
bilan en dix ans entre 2012 et 2016 il
est temps de bateaux y en a tant qui
sont restés une attente qui sont sortis
et bien remplaçons ceux qui sont sortis
et on rentre dans un dialogue de sourd
depuis maintenant depuis le début de
l'année alors que la solution pourrait
être assez facilement trouver même si on
sait qu'un des négociations ça pourrait
être assez facilement trouver en tout
cas au milieu de ce bras de fer certains
de vos collègues pêcheurs ont le
sentiment d'être pris en otage certains
notamment à boulogne-sur-mer estime
avoir perdu jusqu'à la moitié de leur
exploitation depuis le mois d'avril
comment se traduit ce manque à gagner
d'une peur nous avons été accompagnés
par l'europe en ce qui concerne les
aides à l'arrêt pendant
plus qu'à quatre à cinq semaines voire
une deuxième salve pour ceux notamment
qui pouvait justifier d'un dommage et
d'une longue période
de fréquentation des eaux britanniques
donc c'est un lieu quelque part mais de
provisoire au et des no no no fleuty sur
les différentes façades autres france
normandie et bretagne mais les pêcheurs
d'abord n'ont pas envie de vivre
subventions ils veulent vivre de leur
travail et on sait très bien que ça ne
peut être qu'une solution tout à fait
tout à fait provisoire donc oui certains
ont perdu
alors une partie de leur chiffre
d'affaires partiellement compensée
d'autres perdre en perdent en
en qualité en rendement de production
notamment ceux qui vont se réfugier dans
l'es6 12000 anglais la bande côtière
quand il fait mauvais temps et d'autres
côtés notamment os cotentin ne peuvent
plus accéder à
certains n'acceptent seront ils seront
encore plus nombreux à compter du 30
octobre et c'est cela en fait qu'ils
sont en situation est vraiment critique
alors pour le député ministre de jersey
relais les pêcheurs français
n'obtiennent pas naissance tout
simplement parce que je cite il n'envoie
pas les preuves que ces navires pêcher
déjà dans les eaux britanniques avant le
break site alors on sait que c'est
extrêmement complexe d'apporter ses
preuves
alors je crois tout d'abord que on
souffre notamment avec les îles anglo
normandes jersey et guernesey du fait
que tout ça transitent par bruxelles et
par londres 1 ça fait des circuits
administratifs extrêmement long
manifestement toutes les informations
quand elles partent deux pas des régions
ou de paris n'arrive pas complètement
non plus à jersey donc ça veut dire qu'à
un moment donné il ya de la perte en
ligne donc ça c'est assez
incompréhensible mais ça semble est une
réalité donc dans l'ancien traité dit
bête granville qui était une quelque
chose un peu critiquable c'est sûr mais
qui fonctionnait finalement
on avait deux à trois réunions par an
normand-breton janvier pour avoir un
dialogue direct et ça c'était bien donc
ça ça permettrait déjà de mettre de
l'huile dans le tuyau je puis dire et
puis
aussi sur tout de suite les difficultés
ça concerne des bateaux de moins de 12
mètres qui n'ont pas de moyens satellite
à bord n'y était pas obligé puisque
certains sont tout simplement une barre
de 7 ou 8 mai avec juste une petite
cabine pour protéger un homme
et les donc toutes les données étaient
saisis sur des papiers et parfois sur
des zones de pêche quand vous mettez la
zone de pêche elle peut être tantôt
jersiaise tantôt française et descendre
plus bas dans le détail est extrêmement
compliqué d'autres on sait on saisit sa
sur leur informatique mais depuis le
temps alors on a des cas où le pc tout
simplement pris l'eau est inutilisable
et donc qui est comme ça des pertes en
ligne qui se font donc un minimum de
bienveillance aurait sur certains
dossiers on voit des dossiers sont
bloqués parce qu'ils apportent la preuve
pour dix jours et non pas onze jours bon
très clairement par ce moment où un
bateau et à dix jours
merci beaucoup en tout cas marc hadley
d'avoir apportez votre témoignage est de
nous avoir aidé à y voir plus clair sur
ce dossier assez complète c'est
effectivement alors paris at il les
moyens de faire plier londres avec ses
menaces faut-il aller plus loin pour
obtenir des licences supplémentaires
pour nos pêcheurs français on attend
toujours vos réactions sur le compteur
télégramme d'ayrté france place à notre
face à face
[Musique]
et
avec nous pourrons parler ce soir
françois pour les métis journaliste
spécialiste des questions européennes
bonsoir françois pour les métis merci
d'être avec nous à vos côté geoffrey
boulet mombreux des patriotes bonsoir à
vous et merci d'être là également on a
entendu ce témoignage de pêcheurs en
tout cas londres ne semble pas jouer ne
jouent pas le jeu un 10/10 paris la
france qui va donc interdire aux bateaux
de pêche britannique de débarquer dès
mardi prochain si ça ne s'arrangeait pas
c'est ce qui va faire plier nos amis
anglais geoffrey ball est selon vous
vous êtes optimiste sur l'issue de ce
problème
on verra
effectivement une pièce importante que
d'empêcher les débouchés simplement
économique de la pêche anglès en france
mais je pense qu'il ne faut pas non plus
se tromper de sujet et ne pas oublier la
responsabilité en réalité du
gouvernement français dans la situation
très compliquée que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui il faut rappeler que
l'accord dont ton compte est aujourd'hui
les conditions d'application en marge du
bric site a été négocié par l'union
européenne et que ô surprise nos
intérêts semblent ne pas avoir été pris
pleinement en compte parce que qu'est ce
que l'on voit le le pêcheur que vous
avez invité avant lundi on a un problème
sur cha concret sur comment démontrer
l'antériorité de la pêche de bateaux
français dans les eaux britanniques pour
obtenir les fameuses licences et ce
problème touche en particulier les
petits bateaux qui ne sont pas équipés
et qui n'ont pas qu'ils ne peuvent pas
formalisé ce traçage et si vous voulez
c'est un peu les mêmes problèmes que
l'on voit avec l'agriculture c'est le
même monde toujours l'union européenne
lorsqu'elle lorsqu elle négocie pense
aux gros dans ce gros exploitation
d'agriculture pense aux gros armateurs
pense aux gros pêcheurs qui sont bien
équipés et oublient les petits et donc
dans cet oubli des petits qui sont la
cause des difficultés que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui il ya évidemment
une responsabilité politique de la
france qui n'a pas su défendre
correctement au niveau européen les
pêcheurs français qui n'a pas aidé ti
fier ce problème et qui donc a mal cadré
les négociations et aujourd'hui un mal
cadré les conditions d'application de
cet accord qui pour
rigoler on va donner la parole tout de
même à françois pour les matières sont
et pardonnez-moi dessus la
responsabilité du gouvernement français
nous qu'ils ont beau jeu aujourd'hui de
montrer les muscles ça permet de mieux
faire oublier le propre responsabilité
la responsabilité du gouvernement
français françois pour les mathis qui a
mal négocié les intérêts de de nos
pêcheurs et notamment des petits vous
êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic
c'est vrai qu'on a négocié de manière
assez rapide parce qu'il fallait faire
vite l'échéance était là le bric sites
étaient en route et c'est en décembre
qu'il fallait boucler à tout prix cet
accord alors ici dans cet acte aura des
imperfections il n'était pas prévu dans
cet accord notamment que les gens de
faire la preuve finalement de leur
présence dans les eaux anglaises
de manière précise ça n'était pas prévu
dans l'accord nous qu'il ya quelques
imprécisions qui pose un véritable
problème néanmoins je crois qu'il ya une
réalité c'est qu'on joue à se faire peur
ne tirons pas peur des mots entre le
gouvernement de boris johnson et la
france il ya vraiment un espèce de jeu
de montrer ses muscles il est évident
que boris johnson joue un petit peu à
faire peur et
ça va se passer un peu comme ça est ce
que la france a les moyens de faire
plier la grande bretagne je pense que
oui pour pas oublier quand même que 80%
de la pêche britannique va vers l'europe
et danser 82% une part très importante
vers la france et donc les britanniques
ont besoin de la france ont besoin
d'exporter leurs poissons en france
puisqu'il n'arrive pas à ne consommer
chez eux et donc l'un est un moyen de
rétorsion très facile qui consiste
effectivement a bloqué le débarquement
des bateaux de pêche britannique sur les
ports français il ya d'autres moyens de
détention qui sont mis en en filigrane
notamment en matière énergétique puisque
vous le savez des deux jersey et l'île
de guernesey sont alimentés en
électricité par le continent c'est à
dire par la france effectivement de
faire quelques coupures
à croire un peu la pression tout ça
c'est un petit peu un jeu de pour ce
faire peur donc il n'est pas dit qu'on
ira jusqu à des solutions extrêmes mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya un véritable
problème donné deux des deux côtés
d'ailleurs les français font attention
parce que si les français ne réagissent
pas suffisamment c'est les pêcheurs qui
prisent bleus risquent de prendre le
relais et de manière peut-être violente
ce qu'on essaye à tout prix d'éviter et
donc du côté anglais boris johnson qui
n'est pas très motivée par le problème
de la pêche lui même qui représente
quand même une partie très limité de
l'économie britannique oui je donne
effectivement tâte un peu le terrain
pour savoir jusqu'où il peut aller avec
la france donc tout ça est un petit peu
un jeu du qui arrive rarement un autre 1
à qu il faudra bien un accord alors j'y
mets ta est sur la même ligne que vous
elle pense aussi qu'on peut faire payer
en tout cas elle l'espère plutôt les
poissons n'ont pas de nationalité et les
pêcheurs anglais en ont bien profité
mais il faut être diplomate geoffrey
bolets il faut rester diplomate on fait
bien effectivement de montrer les
muscles de bondir aussi comme l'a dit
françois pour les métis les menaces sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique
notamment c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera
à nos fins puisque selon vous le
gouvernement avait négocié en amont
willam allégations et non mais je pense
qu'il faut rester bienveillant pour
entamer des discussions raisonnable avec
les britanniques je ne pense pas qu'il
soit très intelligent par exemple de
menacé de couper l'électricité à jersey
et guernesey parce qu'il n'est pas très
humaniste les habitants de ces îles ne
sont pour rien dans ces problèmes que
connaissent aujourd'hui les pêcheurs
français et ce conflit avec le royaume
uni donc non il faut je pense revenir un
peu sur terre d'autant que si les
britanniques celle dans de telles
conditions par exemple ils sont
suffisamment j'allais dire malin ou four
c'est une question de point de vue pour
se venger ensuite sur d'autres dossiers
et personne n'a intérêt ce qui lui une
escalade à ce que d'autres secteurs de
l'économie soit concerné est d'autant
que si les escalades je rappelle que
nous n'avons pas à une toutes les clés
toutes les cartes en main notre
politique commerciale est décidé à
bruxelles on n'en fallait une partie des
conséquences dans ce dossier précisément
et les britanniques sont toujours plus
agile et plus habile que nous pour nous
faire payer si jamais nous allons trop
loin donc ça pose d'ailleurs de manière
globale le problème de la souveraineté
je rappelle que l'un des problèmes
majeurs des pêcheurs français n'est pas
que l'accès aux eaux britanniques c'est
d'abord le pillage de nos eaux par les
pêcheurs aux européens et là dans la
plus grande légalité européenne puisque
c'est l'union européenne qui gère qui
gère l'accès au mausolée quotas etc et
ça c'est un problème majeur et ça
concerne pas les anglais si les pêcheurs
français avait plus de ressources dans
les eaux françaises c'est à dire très
concrètement si par exemple les pêcheurs
néerlandais qui ont été souvent dénoncé
par les fédérations de pêche en france
parce qu'elles paient les eaux
françaises elle n'agissait pas aussi
librement nous aurions peut-être moins
le besoin d'aller dans les eaux
britanniques plus poissonneuses pour
ramener du poisson vous voyez le
problème est global à chaque fois ils
touchent à notre souveraineté et il ne
faut pas se laisser on va dire je
devrais mollet en tout cas on a d'autres
messages
désolé geoffrey mollet écoutez moi on a
un pin soleil tient c'est joli surnom
les britishs font comme ils veulent ils
ont fait mariner les européens pour le
break site pendant un bon moment 30 soit
pour les mathis c'est vrai que parfois
ça peut donner cette impression
les anglais voilà qui qui ne tiennent
pas leurs engagements il sonne en tout
cas ils qui font un petit peu comme ils
veulent
je crois qu'il faut comprendre encore
une fois que la pêche représente une
part très limitée de l'ensemble de
l'économie aussi bien britannique
d'ailleurs qu'européenne et je pense qu
au delà il ya un véritable problème de
relation entre les britanniques et
l'europe et en particulier entre les
branches britannique et la france
pourquoi on vous savez que le
contentieux est quand même lourd il ya
un contentieux au niveau des frontières
au niveau du passage des immigrés vers
la grande bretagne à travers la manche
mais il ya aussi ce problème de la pêche
bref il ya une véritable incompréhension
pour l'instant c'est vrai qu'on ne fait
pas beaucoup d'efforts pour essayer de
se comprendre mais des deux côtés et en
particulier du côté de boris johnson qui
manifestement pousse un petit peu les
pions un peu l'eau en sachant que pour
lui c'est pas véritablement son problème
ou en pensant que c'est pas son problème
or c'est son problème parce que si on
veut véritablement réglé ce problème là
il faut effectivement le faire de
manière sage pour éviter qu'on en arrive
à de véritables combats navals je
rajouter une chose c'est que quand même
au sur le plan européen pour la france
c'est très important parce que l'europe
n'est pas forcément aussi solidaire quel
tour elle espérait que les pays
européens autour de la france sont pas
aussi solidaire vis-à-vis de la france
qu'il pourrait l'être ils sont un peu
moins intéressés par la question de la
pêche et peut-être que brune johnson
joue un peu celle car cela en disant si
je peut isoler la france par rapport aux
autres 27 c'est peut-être une manière
pour moi de les forcer finalement à
céder et ce jeu là aussi existe mais je
rappelle quand même que la pêche je suis
à maintenant lorsque nous étions un
ensemble cohérent on arriver finalement
à s'entendre un peu près correctement
puisqu'il y avait pas de problème d'eau
territoriales
simplement on essayé de répartir des
quotas de pêche non n'était pas disons
sommes dominés par les questions de re2
de zones territoriales en tout cas peu
d'intérêt on vous dit au niveau européen
peu d'intérêt peut-être aussi en france
parce que on a essayé de chercher les
réactions des candidats à la
présidentielle sur ce thème on en n'a
pas trouvé beaucoup l'une des rares
c'est et xavier bertrand je vous propose
justement de les compter
depuis dix mois nous pêcheurs attendent
leurs licences de pêche des mesures
fortes de rétorsion vis-à-vis des
britanniques au niveau français et
européen doivent être mises en place
urgemment pour les faire plier geoffrey
bollée c'est un sujet qui n'intéresse
pas grand monde en france pourtant il ya
un sacré manque à gagner pour nos
pêcheurs français
mais mais comme tous les sujets en fait
économique le problème c'est que les
politiques français n'ont pas de vraies
solutions importées un contrat on n'a
pas les clés c'est pas nous qui
négocions les grandes politiques
commerciales donc après on ne fait que
payer les pots cassés et les politiques
s'agitent un peu pour faire croire
qu'ils peuvent faire quelque chose vous
faire croire qu'ils ont un souci des
difficultés de telle ou telle profession
donc là c'est très clair avec les
pêcheurs si la plupart des hommes
politiques sinon c'est simplement parce
qu'ils n'ont rien à proposer et ils
n'ont rien à proposer c'est parce qu'en
dehors de l'union européenne il n'y a
rien à faire voilà donc nous c'est pour
ça que aux patriots avec - filippo on
aidé par des partisans de fric si c'est
à dire la sortie de la france de l'union
européenne qui nous permettrait donc là
sur cette question de la pêche ça serait
très concrets qui nous permettrait
d'agir et pour le coup d'avoir une
discussion d'égal à égal avec les
britanniques conformément à tous nos
intérêts par rapport à ce que disait
votre intervenant juste avant soulignant
qu' avant donc cette histoire du bric
site les pêcheurs français a finalement
n'avaient pas de souci je me dois de
rappeler que si ils en avaient ils ont
ils ont à faire face à la concurrence
des pêcheurs néerlandais des pêcheurs
belges qui viennent dans nos zones pillé
nos opinions nos poissons et c'est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles on ressent
ce besoin s'ils pressent d'aller dans
des eaux britanniques y sont très
poissonneuses nous vous voyez si on
était hors de l'union européenne on
pourrait littéralement chassé les
pêcheurs européens de novo et à voir
avec les britanniques des relations tout
à fait cordiale est conforme aux
intérêts des deux parties françois fall
et mathis beau le grand défenseur de
l'europe vous vous partagez le svendsen
diagnostic je crois il faut être
réaliste les poissons n'ont pas de
territoire et donc lorsqu'on dit on va
plier les eaux de x ou y sera pas
véritablement de sens parce que les
poissons bouge il bouge d'une zone à
l'autre alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
aller piller quelque chose chaque chaque
pays finalement à une pêche organisée et
cette pêche est organisé selon des
règles réglementation qui sont
effectivement tracé sur le plan européen
mais elles sont passées par les
ministres les ministres de la pêche et
parmi ces mises la pêche on sait très
bien que la france a un poids assez
important donc il ne s'agit pas d'aller
piller ou de papier il s'agit
effectivement de respecter un minimum de
quotas le problème encore une fois est
posée par le fait que l'angleterre
n'étant plus pauvre de l'union
européenne elle a rétabli ses frontières
maritimes etc zone
d'exclusion maritime et c'est là le
problème avec cette
originalité géographique qui fait que
l'angleterre à deux territoires de petit
jean qui sont quasiment au contact du
continent jersey et guernesey donc les
pêcheurs de granville qui sortent à
peine de leurs ports finalement tourner
tout de suite dans les eaux
territoriales britanniques ce qui
effectivement est un véritable problème
donc encore une fois il s'agit pas de
savoir qu'il va plier qui il s'agit de
savoir est ce qu ont tous un accord à la
fois pour des quotas de pêche et à la
fois pour cette question des licences
qui encore une fois n'était pas prévu
dans le traité de décembre dernier merci
françois paul et mathis merci geoffrey
bollea d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
face à face ce soir
autre dossier autre bras de fer post
break site entre paris et londres la
crise migratoire l' ocde publié
aujourd'hui un rapport consacré à
l'impact budgétaire de ces migrants sur
ses pays membres et notamment la france
et le royaume uni conclusion ces
populations ne coûte presque rien aux
états qui d accueil emilie gogh h
une étude qui va à l'encontre de
certaines idées reçues selon l' ocde les
immigrés donnent plus qu'ils ne
reçoivent pour le cas de la france en
particulier la contribution budgétaire
net des personnes nées à l'étranger est
même positive
1,02 pour cent du produit intérieur brut
les immigrés contribuent plus en
prestations sociales et en impôts qu'ils
ne reçoivent en prestations
individuelles ça veut dire en fait qui
contribuent au financement des dépenses
publiques pure à l'échelle d'environ 1
milliard 3 en ce qui concerne la france
donc au paiement du service de la dette
et aux dépenses militaires ces
populations reçoivent plus de
prestations familiales et occupent
davantage de logements sociaux que les
non immigrés mais elles sont en revanche
les et dans d'autres domaines en
parallèle ils reçoivent moins de
retraite ils reçoivent moins de
deux prestations de santé et d'éducation
c'est de l'autre côté de l'équation que
la différence se fait c'est à dire non
pas que les immigrés reçoivent plus de
prestations individuelles mais qu'ils
contribuent moins ils contribuent moins
parce que leur intégration reste moins
favorables sur le marché du travail que
7 des natives en effet seuls 56% des
immigrés présents en france sont
employés s'ils étaient mieux intégrées
sur le marché du travail leur
contribution au budget de l'état déjà
positive le serait encore plus
le sénat résistons vaut face à la
prolongation et aux règles édictées par
le passé ni terre adopté par l'assemblée
nationale le texte qui divise à
prolonger l'état d'urgence sanitaire
jusqu'en juillet 2022 est examiné
aujourd'hui par les sénateurs le sénat
qui est dominé par l'opposition de
droite s'apprête à inclure une clause de
revoyure le but obliger le gouvernement
à repasser devant le parlement pour
étendre les dispositions au delà du 28
février le palais du luxembourg dans
lequel celui ci s'est terminée
manifestation contre le pass sanitaires
et un nouveau tour de vis en russie où
un nouveau record de quatre comme il
vient d'être enregistré plus de 40000
nouvelles infections et plus de 1100
décès ces dernières 24 heures plus
d'explications dans les rues de moscou
avec notre correspondant antoine
claireaux ça y est c'est officiel depuis
ce matin à moscou tous les services non
essentiels affiche désormais portes
closes pour une durée de 11 jours cinéma
salon de beauté salle de sport magasins
de vêtements ou encore de souvenirs
comme ici ne pourront accueillir de
public ce n'est pas encore un
confinement au sens strict cafés et
restaurants font de la vente à emporter
tandis que théâtres et musées reste
ouvert mais avec une jauge réduite de
50% et sous condition de présenter un
pass sanitaires dans le même temps les
entreprises sont priés de placer au
moins un tiers de leurs effectifs en
télétravail avec toujours le même
objectif affiché limiter la circulation
de la population et donc du virus ce qui
a eu pour conséquence un départ massif
des moscovites en dehors de la capitale
ce mercredi soir le trafic ressembler à
celui d'un vendredi de départs en
vacances et la question qui se pose
maintenant est la suivante cette mesure
ne va-t-elle durer que 11 jours comme
annoncé par les autorités en effet en
fonction de l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire il est possible que cette
période soit allongé dans le temps ou
bien que les restrictions prennent une
nouvelle forme
la chine redouble également de
précaution contre le coc vide décision à
près de trois mois de l'ouverture des jo
d'hiver 2022 qui doivent se dérouler à
pékin depuis quelques jours le nord du
pays fait face à une résurgence de la
pandémie résurgence certes limité 23
nouveaux cas de contamination ont été
rapportés aujourd'hui mais les autorités
mis sur la prudence les explications en
bref et en images
[Musique]
on
[Rires]
[Musique]
tous
nous
[Musique]
[Rires]
il
[Musique]
non
[Rires]
[Musique]
oh
bon
[Musique]
après dix-huit mois de fermeture
l'australie et les autorise de son côté
ses citoyens un voyage et le taux
d'adultes disposant d'un schéma vaccinal
complet se rapproche de l'objectif des
80 % cette réouverture des frontières ne
concernera pas tous les états selon le
premier ministre
à partir de lundi prochain les
australiens entièrement vacciner
pourront voyager à l'étranger en
nouvelle galles du sud dans le victoria
et dans le territoire de la capitale les
frontières seront ouvertes
l'australie se connecte à nouveau et je
peux vous dire que personne n'est plus
heureux que moi de voir cela se produire
nous allons continuer à voir cela se
produire dans les mois prochains et
notamment avant noël
à londres deuxième jour
d'une extradition
diffusé des milliers de documents
classés confidentiels très affaibli
julian assange a refusé de comparaître
aujourd'hui après avoir participé à une
partie des débats par visioconférence
ses soutiens restent nombreux devant la
haute cour de londres et ont même bloqué
une rue de la capitale plus de
précisions sur place avec à notre envoyé
spécial katia technique
aujourd'hui pour le deuxième jour de la
demande d'extradition en appel les
avocats de julian assange se sont
exprimés
james lewis le représentant des états
unis auprès de la cour a contesté dans
tous ses détails l'expertisé
psychiatrique est permis ou lanceurs
dallaire d'échapper à l'extradition les
américains tout simplement ni le risque
suicidaire qui était le pivot de la
précédente décision l'avocat de julian
assange a aujourd'hui assuré que l'état
mental du danseur d' alerte était de
nature à déclencher des envies
suicidaires que quelles que soient les
conditions de détention aux états unis
il pouvait attenter à sa vie il rappelle
surtout la loi britannique elle protège
ce type de prisonniers qui ont des
troubles psychiatriques c'est vraiment
la clé de la défense de julian assange
alors que de terribles menaces planent
sur lui en cas d'extradition on écoute
le rédacteur en chef de wikileaks
kristinn hrafnsson
bien qu'ils essaient de minimiser cette
possibilité les charges contre lui
pourrait le mettre en prison pour cent
soixante quinze ans ça pourrait être
l'issue de son procès en plus de cela il
serait mis en isolement c'est une
certitude quoi qu'ils essaient de dire
il clame que leurs garanties soient
solides mais elles ne le sont pas c'est
l'estimation d'amnesty international et
de tous ceux qui ont connaissance du
dossier
l'avocat de julian assange a aussi
rappelé que la cia avait engagé des
discussions pour éliminer du lan assange
ou encore le kidnapper et que cela en
disait long sur le traitement qui
pourrait lui être réservé aux états unis
sans oublier le vol de documents
d'avocats dans un bureau les filatures
de sa compagne l'espionnage à
l'ambassade d'équateur les analyses adn
de couches volet d'un fils de julian
assange on parle de tout cela avec le
père julian assange
cette affaire c'est comme un zombie qui
revient du monde des morts scandale
après scandale ils nous ont accusés mais
le témoin islandais que le fbi à
soudoyer pour témoigner contre julian a
été mis en prison c'est un pédophile
condamné un fraudeur condamné et il
s'est rétracté
même l'espionnage de julian par la cia a
été révélée à tout le monde trente
agents de la cia ont témoigné au
reporter de yahoo news un autre scandale
le parquet de la couronne et le parquet
suédois qui conspirent ensemble pour
garder julian à l'ambassade aussi
longtemps que possible jusqu'à ce qu'ils
trouvent un moyen de le capturer et de
le traîner devant le tribunal pour
extradition vers les etats-unis un autre
scandale
voici les éléments de plaidoirie de
l'équipe de défense en cette seconde
journée d'appel qui compte bien sûr
conforter la première décision alors
qu'ici à londres des centaines de
personnes se sont mobilisées depuis hier
contre l'extradition du lanceur d'
alerte le délibéré sera rendu dans
plusieurs semaines
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
aymeric montville philosophe recteur en
chef de la revue la pensée auteurs
julienne assange en danger de mort aux
éditions delga bonsoir monsieur mobile
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france danger de mort justement on
en parle puisque la défense a insisté
sur le risque de suicide un de julian
assange en cas d'extradition vers les
états unis malgré les assurances de
washington sur le sort qui lui serait
réservé pour vous c'est un risque réel
oui il ya le ce risque là qui est tout à
fait réel en cas d'extradition et il
faut aussi parler du risque qu'il y a à
rester dans cette prison
si on s'interroge aussi sur ceux des
conditions conditions de détention ces
conditions de santé le rapporteur de
l'onu sur la torture nilsson their à
parler de torture institutionnels
la grande bretagne n'est né n'est pas
blanche non plus dans cette dans cette
affaire pour l'instant il me semble que
il ya quelque chose qui complètement
extrajudiciaires et qui préside à tout
ça qu'il est peut-être espérer qu'il n'y
aura pas une
extradition tout de suite c'est qu'il ya
une autre affaire concomitante qui n'a
rien à voir mais qui est arrivé au même
manqué sert de la fère et stein
d'ailleurs le juge bared soeur avait dit
nous ne pouvons pas extrader assange
parce que epstein s'est suicidé en
prison on vient que les prisons
américaines sont sans dangereuses ou
j'ajoute j'ajouterai
alors ce moment vous avez comme les
états unis qui demandent quand même
avoir comparé que le prince andrew
ça me laisse un petit espoir du côté du
fait que ça ne se passerait pas aux
états unis mais c'est pas pour ça que
c'est pas dangereux en angleterre pour
l'instant des affrontements entre
puissances de l'otan on a vu avec la
france que
dans l'otan ne ne préside pas de ne
prédisait pas forcément que vous avez
des bonnes relations tout le temps au
beau fixe la faire des sous marins
australiens on était un exemple et je
crois que c'est ce qu'il est tout petit
peu d'espoir pour peut-être même trempe
et on va voir dans les semaines qui
viennent parce que malheureusement il ya
un accord d'extradition qui est qui qui
est essentielle mais à mon avis c'est ça
qui est pour l'instant en brume les
relations entre les états unis et la
grande bretagne c'est quand même la
famille royale qui est impliqué dans la
sphère publique vous pensez que cette
affaire évidemment qu'elle est politique
mais ça voudrait dire si on vous suit
que les juges dans cette histoire ne
serait pas totalement indépendants
devaient aussi examiner si cette
accusation était politique ce qui est
quand même très très drôle ça fait
partie de leur
d3 réquisits tison de cette procédure
outre bien sûr là son état de santé
sa capacité à se défendre
donc évidemment que on peut aussi leur
tournée aussi la même chose en tout cas
je veux pas refus d'extradition est ce
que ça pourrait changer selon vous à
combien s'élève le risque aujourd'hui
que la justice
examine sa position et on renvoie on
voit un gène à san jose et à ce que je
vois c'est que les mobilisations
populaires augmente je vois les images
allons donc j'ai les désinformateurs là
bas c'est une forte mobilisation et je
crois que les gens ont compris qu'il
fallait lier la défense de la liberté
d'expression ah je dirais un combat
excusez moi je vais je dire un vieux mot
un gros mot l'anti-impérialisme de la
lutte classique on contre l'otan je
pense qu'il est là vous avez quelque
part de gauche et puis des gens de
droite de bonne volonté c'est à dire on
défend la liberté d'expression mais en
plus le droit des peuples à disposer d
eux mêmes parce que je rappelle que ce
qui est scandaleux c'est pas seulement
qu'on le persécutent lui c'est que ceux
qui le persécutent il a rêvé leur crime
de guerre et que ces gens là ne sont pas
sérieux qui devrait être sur le banc des
accusés il faut vraiment retourner la
chose et pour ça il faut une révolte
populaire je pense qu'on s'en sortira
dans cette histoire que si on arrive à
agréger toutes
toutes les volontés pour le faire
libérer pour différentes raisons c'est à
dire la liberté d'expression et la lutte
anti-impérialiste le point justement de
ces soutiens que l'on voit ces
manifestations devant la cour
aujourd'hui ça peut peser dans ce procès
réellement seul en vo mais je crois
aussi que même le contexte de
désagrégement de l'auto ou même des
lunes des dirigeants s'en rendre compte
le fait que on comprend on a
l'impression que c'est une énergie
complètement anachronique et puis qui
nous pousse à la guerre j'ai en moi en
tant qu'éditeur j'ai été attaqué par le
rapport de l'irsn qui a un rapport
piloté par l'école note le ministère des
armées écrit par quelqu'un qui était à
l'otan depuis deux ans auparavant tout
simplement parce que j'avais rencontrés
dans le cas de la publication d'un livre
l'ambassadeur de chine donc je fais je
suis dans une liste d'agents d'influencé
suivant c'est grotesque bientôt ils vont
aimer c'est la même pour procédure c'est
l'otan singer d'un autre dans nos
politiques intérieures persécute des
citoyens des citoyens qui évidemment
simplement de l'information il faut que
les gens se rendent compte que tout ça
tout ça c'est la même politique jeudi au
moment de sa saison et j'ai un auteur
qui s'était 44 fois c'est dans cet
ouvrage met tout ça ça participe de ses
ingérences dans notre droit démocratique
du fait que le droit international et
contre considérablement bafouille comme
quand vous voyez que même l'onu n'est
pas respectée alors qu'ils disent
clairement que assange et torturés c'est
le droit international qui est bafouée
ce sont ce sont nos vies qui sont
maltraités par ce système impérialiste
porté par l'otan il faut dénoncer le
temps il faut lier la libération d'un
singe à des manifestations franche et
massive contre cette guerre qui va nous
imposer le notre état-major prétend que
nous aurions nous serions dans un un
risque de haute sécurité que nous
devrions préparer des guerres de haute
intensité mais contre qui pourquoi dans
le bon sens
que tout simplement on doit pas révéler
des secrets d'état de pays
il ya cet avis là aussi qu'est ce qu'on
répond tout factuellement c'est ce qu'il
a révélé des crimes effectivement ces
crimes se tout ce qu'il avait révélée
s'est avéré ça n'a jamais été démenti
donc dans ces cas là il faudrait plutôt
s'interroger sur ceux qui ont commis ces
crimes mais comme ce sont eux qui le
persécutent je crois que la chose est
très claire merci beaucoup et on est
calme en ville je rappelle que vous êtes
l'auteur de julien assange en danger de
mort aux éditions delga merci d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
nouvelles tensions entre washington et
pékin en cause la présence de soldats
américains sur l'île de taïwan et une
présence à fustiger par la chine les
explications
de
la méfiance entre la chine et les etats
unis a franchi un nouveau cap la
présidente taïwanaise a confirmé ce
jeudi la présence de soldats américains
dans son pays en tant que formateur
suscitant immédiatement l'ire de pékin
nous nous opposons fermement à toute
forme des changes officielles et de
contacts militaires entre les états unis
et taïwan nous nous opposons aussi à
l'ingérence américaine dans les affaires
internes de la chine les etats unis ont
récemment tenté à plusieurs reprises de
montrer leurs muscles dans le détroit de
taiwan suscitant des provocations et des
troubles et envoyant un mauvais signal
aux forces indépendantistes de taïwan
c'est la première fois qu'un dirigeant
taïwanais confirme la présence des états
unis sur son sol depuis le départ de la
dernière garnisons américaines en 1979
dans un souci de coopération
internationale les états unis avaient
confirmé cette semaine leur souhait
d'accorder une participation
significative de taiwan à l'onu là aussi
en provoquant une réaction de la part de
la chine
si les états unis continuent à jouer la
carte de taïwan cela va certainement
changer la donne et faire peser des
risques énormes sur les relations
sino-américaines porter gravement
atteinte à la paix et à la stabilité
dans le détroit de taiwan et aux propres
intérêts des états unis
la chine considère taïwan comme l'une de
ses provinces quel souhaité réunifier au
reste du pays mais la diplomatie
américaine justifie cette position par
l'apport significatif que constituerait
la présence de taiwan au sein de
l'organisation onusienne
la déclaration a souligné que nous
soutenons la capacité de taiwan a
participé de manière significative à
l'onu et à apporter son expertise
précieuse pour relever les nombreux
défis mondiaux auxquels nous sommes
confrontés
cela inclut la santé publique mondiale
l'environnement le changement climatique
l'aide au développement les normes
techniques et la coopération économique
également
le bureau des affaires taiwanaises sous
la coupe du gouvernement chinois a
immédiatement réfuté le droit de
participation de l'île aux nations unies
mais de son côté le gouvernement
taïwanais a remercié washington pour son
soutien le ministre des affaires
étrangères appelle à l' union des
démocraties à travers le monde
[Applaudissements]
dans une situation la démocratie est
menacée dans différentes parties du
monde nous devons travailler et nous
soutenir mutuellement l'union fait la
force la division fait la faiblesse
c'est aussi simple que cela
la position américaine sur le dossier
n'est pas nouvelle mais ce rappel
intervient après la présence accrue ces
derniers temps de l'armée chinoise dans
le ciel taïwanais
la semaine passée joe biden avait
affirmé que les forces américaines
pourraient intervenir si pékin décidé
d'attaquer taïwan ce qui a accru la
confiance de la présidente taïwanaise
envers washington
joe biden se rend en europe pour une
tournée diplomatique à fort enjeu près
des semaines compliquées le président
américain va avoir l'occasion de
discuter directement avec ses alliés une
rencontre avec emmanuel macron est
prévue demain juste avant le sommet du
g20 à rome pour en parler on retrouve
notre correspondant à washington thomas
bonnet brousse
[Musique]
départ donc du président américain pour
rome a été décalée de quelques heures
pour quelles raisons
et bien tout simplement parce que joe
biden a été rattrapé par l'actualité
nationale américaine il s'est exprimé en
fin de matinée pour présenter un nouveau
plan d'investissement revu à la baisse
et ce afin de contenter une partie du
camp démocrate il espère maintenant que
ce plan sera validée par le congrès très
prochainement mais cela illustre les
difficultés sur la scène politique
intérieure de joe biden et ses
difficultés elles ont un impact plus
fâcheux que de simplement reportée de
quelques heures son départ pour l'europe
puisque le washington post nous rappelle
que sur les 19 autres pays que composent
le g20 15 d'entre eux n'ont actuellement
pas d'ambassadeur qui a été directement
choisis par joe biden en réalité depuis
qu'il est arrivé à la maison blanche le
président américain n'a pu nommer que
quatre ambassadeurs puisque tu outre
toutes les autres nominations sont
encore suspendus à la validation du
sénat américain et il ya un homme qui
bloquent ces nominations c'est le
sénateur républicain ted cruz qui dit
vouloir faire pression sur le locataire
de la maison blanche afin de le faire
plier de le faire évoluer sur sa
position par rapport au gazoduc north
stream ii et pour joe biden qui ne cesse
de marteler que son arrivée au pouvoir
aux etats-unis coïncide avec le retour
de l'amérique sur la scène
internationale le fait de ne pas avoir
de l'ambassadeur choisi par ses soins
dans un certain nombre de pays
évidemment cela a des conséquences et
thomas malgré ses déboires intérieur
quels sont les objectifs du président
américain lors de ce déplacement en
europe
bien selon jack sullivan qui est le
conseiller à la sécurité nationale de la
maison blanche les représentants
américains se rendent en europe avec
plein d'énergie avec la volonté de
solidifier les unions entre les pays
alliés et washington jack sullivan qui
écarte un peu rapidement les divergences
entre des chancelleries européennes et
les états unis alors on sait que les
contacts ont repris ces dernières
semaines entre paris et washington on
sait aussi que l'union européenne a
expliqué que 6dans était clos après
cette crise des sous marins mais
évidemment le sujet sera au coeur des
discussions entre emmanuel macron et joe
biden la question est de savoir quelle
importance il sera donné à cet incident
diplomatique cette crise diplomatique
lors des différentes prises de parole
des deux présidents savoir aussi qu elle
trace a laissé cette crise diplomatique
dans les relations entre les deux pays
quelles traces a aussi laissé leur très
chaotique d'afghanistan des troupes
américaines tout cela va être scrutée
avec attention surtout en l'absence des
présidents russe et chinois lors de ce
sommet du g20 mais évidemment tous ces
enjeux diplomatiques auront aussi une
importance très nationale puisque par
exemple lorsque joe biden va parler
d'écologie à la coop 26 il va aussi et
peut-être même surtout s'adresser aux
électeurs américains à qui il vient de
proposer à un plan d'investissement
justement sur la transition écologique
et puis de son côté l'attitude et les
propos d' emmanuel macron seront scrutés
puisque la crise diplomatique entre
paris et washington est devenu
éminemment politique en france à
quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington
le g20 un grand rendez vous ce week end
et pays donc les plus puissants du monde
au programme à rome la lutte contre le
commis 19 avec une aide qui doit être
renforcé vers les états pauvres la
relance économique mais aussi et surtout
le climat un avant-goût de la coop 26
qui se tiendra dans la foulée à glasgow
sébastien hamard
un g20 aux allures de réunion de crise
c'est ce qui attend les 20 pays les plus
riches du monde qui se réuniront à rome
ce samedi tous ne seront pas présents la
russie et la chine interviendront par
vidéoconférence le coc vider la relance
économique mondiale seront bien sûr au
centre des discussions mais un autre
sujet brûlant de cette rencontre à la
veille de la coop 26 est également au
programme non
le troisième sujet que nous aborderons
au g20 avec beaucoup d'insistance sera
le changement climatique comme je les
dis nous avons les vingt économies les
plus avancées autour de la table ces
vingt économies les plus importantes
représente également 80% des émissions
mondiales et nous avons donc une
responsabilité particulière
des enfants oui la vacherie sponsor a
été parmi les objectifs fixés par les
états membres la neutralité bonne à
l'horizon 2050 et le plafonnement de la
hausse de la température mondiale à 1,5
degré deux missions que l'hétérogénéité
des politiques énergétiques de ces 20
pays complique si la france peut se
targuer d'avoir un plan de transition
sur les rails d'autres pays comme
l'australie plus gros exportateur
mondial de charbon n'ont pas encore
fourni de stratégie concrète bonne
nouvelle cependant la chine premier
émetteur mondial de gaz à effet de serre
vient tout juste de présenter ses
engagements la chine a fixé son pic
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
avant 2030 et la neutralité carbone
avant 2060
un effort pas assez ambitieux selon
certains observateurs
la chine jette une ombre sur l'effort
climatique mondial au vu des
incertitudes économiques internes le
pays semble hésiter à embrasser des
objectifs de court terme plus fort et a
manqué l'occasion de faire preuve
d'ambition le monde ne peut plus se
permettre que ce soit le dernier mot et
pékin doit élaborer des plans de mise en
oeuvre assurant un pic d'émissions avant
2025 ce g20 sera l'occasion de prendre
la température des actions de chacun des
pays membres avant la coop 26 le
lendemain
direction la tunisie pour évoquer cette
aventure d'une chaîne de télévision
annonce hier soir de la haute autorité
de l'audiovisuel pour exercice illégal
de son activité une décision qui
intervient alors que le fondateur du
médian nessma tv nabil karoui a été
remis en liberté et placé sous contrôle
en algérie les correspondances à tunis m
shelly une nouvelle affaire judiciaire
qui éclabousse nabil karoui le président
du parti à calpe tools à la tête de la
chaîne de télévision nessma l'homme
d'affaires a pris mercredi la fermeture
de son antenne par laika
la haute autorité indépendant de la
communication audiovisuelle en cause des
transmissions sans licence de diffusion
après de multiples mises en garde de la
part des autorités tunisiennes écouter
la chaîne nessma tv à retarder le
règlement de son statut juridique depuis
2014 et ce malgré les appels lancés et
les efforts de l'aica à travers de
nombreuses correspondances et réunion
depuis 2014 qui l'avait obligé à prendre
la décision d'arrêter les procédures de
règlement en juillet 2018 la haute
instance a précisé que cette fermeture
était également motivé par des soupçons
de corruption financière et
administrative en cause également l
influence politique exercée sur la
chaîne par celui qui reste aux yeux de
l'état tunisien le chef d'un des
principaux partis d'opposition en 2019
laïque avait déjà procédé à la saisie
des équipements de nessma tv pour des
raisons similaires accompagnées par les
forces de l'ordre la haute autorité a
procédé mercredi à l'arrêt de diffusion
de la chaîne tout en invitant ses
collaborateurs à évacuer les lieux lancé
en 2007 nessma tv avait pour objectif de
proposer des contenus inédits à
destination de la diaspora maghrébine en
europe on peut donc parler d'un vrai
coup de filet audiovisuel puisqu'outre
la chaîne de nabil karoui d'autres
médias comme hannibal tv ou radio coran
ont été sommés également de suspendre
leur diffusion et ce jusqu'à
régularisation de leur situation
reste avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du chômage en france
féministe de travail des abeilles bornes
parlant d'un record depuis 20 ans pour
les embauches au troisième trimestre est
fait sur l'ol du quoi qu'il en coûte et
nous évoquerons 6 à des salaires et le
pouvoir d'achat au coeur de la campagne
présidentielle dans l'édito échos de
jacques sapir
m
[Musique]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions des procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter
les faits ni sur la liste des morts nés
sur l'île d'eubée sécurité hopitalisés
il était nul marque pas ce qu'on peut
vivre malgré cette douleur quand j'ai
écrit à la fois je souffrais parce que
ça me rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
les ong sont devenus en 50 ans des
acteurs incontournables de la société
moderne par leur impact auprès des
gouvernements et du public confondant
régulièrement les grands principes avec
leurs objectifs politiques
ce sont des organisations non
gouvernementales mais pas des
organisations non politiques les ong
développent des stratégies d' influence
qui privilégie l'émotionnel sur le
rationnel le sectarisme de la majorité
d'entre elles les amènent à des
interprétations qui exclut toute pensée
ou comportements n'allant pas dans leur
sens et leur complice n'hésitant pas à
tordre les faits et à utiliser tous les
moyens pour imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce personnage affreux tronics vous
l'avez créé en 2014 dans un but précis
montrer une autre image du continent
africain effectivement c'est d'essayer
de partir des racines des réseaux de
chez nous est montré que les jeunes
africains la nouvelle génération peut
aussi se projeter dans le futur cela
représente quoi pour vous la ferez
futurisme comme on n'a pas eu une
influence sur l'histoire sur le passé on
s'est dit on peut se permettre
d'imaginer un futur où l'afrique serait
un grand continent il ya pas moins de se
développer sans la culture
malheureusement ce qui sort du pays j'ai
le temps que les médias s'intéressent
plus quand il s'agit de la guerre donc à
travers ma musique je veux inviter les
gens à venir découvrir ce beau pays
[Musique]
la communication des modèles mâcon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
victhom est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont il se désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus clownesque justement c'est
une nouvelle forme de communication
assez verticale utiliser des
influenceurs pour un sac hommes
politiques personnelles est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vraiment nouveau
d'utiliser des célébrités pour faire de
la propagande politique on s'en fiche
nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige la
france comme c'est son travail en notre
nom pour nous aider dans notre intérêt à
tous
[Musique]
ni dès 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire le chômage at-il vraiment
baissé en france comme s'en félicite les
ministres du travail elisabeth bornes
parle d'un record depuis 20 ans pour les
embauches au troisième trimestre et fait
selon elle de quoi qu'il en coûte une
interprétation nuancée par certains
syndicats notamment la cgt qui parle de
chômeurs qui ne travaillent pas du tout
et qui ont juste retrouver des contrats
précaires
les salaires et le pouvoir d'achat au
coeur de la campagne présidentielle l
heure où l'inflation s'attaque au porte
monnaie des français la plupart des
candidats s'empare du sujet hausse du
smic à gauche baisse de la fiscalité à
droite le gouvernement affirme hui que
le niveau de vie des français a
progressé depuis l'arrivée d'emmanuel
macron alors qu'ils livraient éléments
de réponse tout à l'heure avec
l'économiste jacques sapir
[Musique]
elisabeth bornes vend donc l'élite du
quoi qu'il en coûte d'amis nice de
travail considère aujourd'hui que ce
choix a permis de faire baisser le
chômage moins de chômeurs peut-être mais
plus précaires selon certains estelle
farges
ils sont plus de 200 mille à avoir
retrouvé le chemin du travail ces trois
derniers mois une bonne nouvelle sur le
front de l'emploi car le chômage pour la
catégorie a est retombé à des niveaux
enregistrés avant l'arrivée de
l'épidémie de covin 19 le nombre
d'inscrits à pôle emploi de catégories a
donc et c'est à dire sans aucune
activité a donc baissé de 5 5% au
troisième trimestre par rapport au
trimestre précédent une bonne nouvelle
c'est ce qu'a souligné la ministre du
travail elisabeth bornes qui y voit les
effets positifs du quoi qu'il en coûte
un nombre record d'embauchés au
troisième trimestre plus de 2,5 millions
d'embauché en cdd de plus d'un mois ou
en cdi
donc c'est un record depuis 20 ans
effectivement on a une baisse de
demandeurs d'emploi de 200 milles sur le
troisième trimestre c'est une bonne
nouvelle et ça montre que les
dispositions qu'on a mis en place
pendant la crise pour protéger les
entreprises et emplois et aussi le plan
de relance portent leurs fruits s'est
défait du quoi qu'il en coûte en
revanche le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi des catégories b et c lui est
en hausse +4 2% au troisième trimestre
ce sont les inscrits à pôle emploi mais
qui exercent une activité réduite ce qui
signifie que ce qui était auparavant
dans la catégorie a ont retrouvé du
travail mais avec des conditions plus ou
moins durables une preuve de précarité
c'est ce qu'a indiqué la cgt à nos
confrères du monde
5,87 un million c'est le nombre de
chômeurs toutes catégories confondues
un nombre qui diminue légèrement depuis
l'été mais qui est tout de même plus
important qu'avant l'arrivée de
l'épidémie est toujours au chapitre et
colas question centrale du pouvoir
d'achat d'ores et déjà très omniprésent
en campagne présidentielle parmi les
pistes proposées par certains candidats
déclarés ou non l'augmentation des
salaires ce matin le maire de paris anne
hidalgo affirmé vouloir augmenter le
smig de 10 à 15% de son côté jean luc
mélenchon a réaffirmé qu'il voulait
remonter ce même smic à 1400 euros nets
ce qui selon lui entraînerait
mécaniquement la hausse des autres
salaires alors à six mois de la
présidentielle la surenchère n'en finit
donc plus la hausse du smic à gauche
mais aussi la baisse de la fiscalité à
droite le gouvernement un flux important
que le niveau de vie des ménages a
progressé depuis l'arrivée d'emmanuel
écran alors qui dit vrai faudra-t-il
passer par cette fameuse hausse des
salaires notamment des plus bas le
peut-on vraiment on en parle tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
dans son édito ico
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques atouts des toits c'est
pourquoi parle-t-on autant des salaires
en ce moment il ya plusieurs raisons
tout d'abord effectivement nous
connaissons une vague d'inflation même
si elle est transitoire elle pèse sur
les ménages elle pèse sur le revenu des
ménages après une deuxième raison c'est
que avec la crise on s'est aperçu que
certains revenus les revenus les plus
élevés les profits les profits des
actionnaires avaient très fortement
augmenté alors ça pose un petit problème
et puis un bain si vous voulez il ya
quand même la troisième raison c'est que
le gouvernement dépense sans compter
celles à la politique du chéquier sortie
adoptée par emmanuel macron bon tout
ceci mais d'une certaine manière la
question des salaires du pouvoir d'achat
sur la table au premier plan mais il
faut savoir que ce n'est pas propre
simplement à la france on a des
problèmes identiques dans de très
nombreux pays développés en particulier
aux états unis où on assiste
actuellement depuis la fin du mois de
septembre à une vague de grèves dont
justement dans les milieux qui sont les
moins payés chez les travailleurs qui
sont le moins payés par jacques un
réponse à cela le gouvernement vous
l'avez dit jean castex a répondu en
disant non le pouvoir d'achat plus
augmenté sous emmanuel macron qu'ils
avaient augmenté sous ses prédécesseurs
ce soit nicolas sarkozy ou françois
hollande alors
jean castex s'est fondée si vous voulez
pour cette déclaration sur un rapport du
sénat si on utilise le rapport que l'os
et dès que le fc e pardon le fc eux
vient de publier bien on vous
effectivement on peut le voir là l'écran
que ces deux là d'un cas c'est que ça
fondamentalement raison seulement il
faut à ce moment-là remarqué trois
choses premièrement c'est un rattrapage
ce qui se passe sous emmanuel macron le
pouvoir d'achat avait fortement baissé
sous nicolas sarkozy conséquence de la
politique de monsieur françois fillon
ils avaient stagné il n'avait repris que
très lentement sous françois hollande et
la reprise avec emmanuel macron ne fait
que corriger d'une certaine manière ce
qui s'était passé antérieur ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point on
raisonne en moyenne or il faut savoir
que on peut avoir des chiffres moyens
qui augmentent fortement et des chiffres
pour les deux premiers déciles c'est à
dire les 20% dès gens qui sont le moins
bien payé qui stagne voix qui régresse
ça c'est un deuxième problème et puis un
troisième problème qui n'est pas pris en
compte dans ce type de graphique c'est
le fait que les dépenses contraintes les
dépenses qu'on est obligé de toutes les
manières de payer à la fin du mois et
bien la part de ces dépenses contraintes
a augmenté depuis une quinzaine d'années
alors quand vous dites que la différence
est importante entre l'évolution pour
les plus pauvres et les plus riches à
quoi vous pensez précisément lien c'est
un calcul que l'insee a fait et l'insee
montrent d'ailleurs que de ce point de
vue là les pauvres subissent plus
l'inflation que les riches alors ya
plusieurs raisons à cela le fait que la
part par exemple de l'énergie dans le
logement du logement la part aussi de la
nourriture est beaucoup plus élevé dans
les ménages les plus pauvres qu'elle ne
l'est dans les ménages les plus riches
qui eux vont pomme par exemple plus
consommée en matière
si vous voulez de divertissement en
hôtel en restaurant qui sont des postes
ou d'une certaine manière il ya eu moins
d'augmentation alors c'est important on
vérifie que si une dizaine d'années
l'écart peut-être de 15% entre les deux
catégories et évidemment c'est quelque
chose qui pèse d'autant plus sur la
perception de l'inflation que ressentent
les français les plus pauvres les
français les plus modestes alors est ce
que ces différences sont uniquement dû à
la consommation dont vous venez de nous
parler non la consommation joue un rôle
extrêmement important mais il ya aussi
l'évolution des revenus et je reviens là
à ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure à
propos de la déclaration de monsieur
jean castex vous pouvez très bien vous
laisser pas du tout contradictoire vous
pouvez très bien avoir
les 10% ou les 20% des revenus les plus
élevés qui voient leurs revenus monter
fortement voire très fortement et les
revenus des 10 ou 20% les plus modestes
qui stagne globalement la moyenne va
continuer à monter mais ça ne va pas
concerner d'une certaine manière les
revenus qui sont en bas de l'échelle
alors c'est important parce que si vous
voulez c'est une erreur qui est commise
assez classiquement par les politiques
est ce que c'est une erreur ou est ce qu
ils le font volontairement ça c'est un
autre problème mais c'est le fait de
parler d'une moyenne 100 immédiatement
données quels sont les critères de
dispersion autour de la moyenne et c'est
bien le problème en france c'est que la
dispersion entre les plus hauts et les
plus faibles est aujourd'hui extrêmement
ouvert alors
une hausse du smic est ce qu'ils ont
quelque part raison pendant nos enfants
oui fondamentalement si vous voulez en
apparence vous prenez que ce soit le
discours d' anne hidalgo le discours de
jean luc mélenchon le discours de
monsieur fabien roussel on lui parle
plutôt d'une augmentation du smic brut
que du smic net mais ça ça revient un
peu de choses aux mains à peu de choses
près au même eh bien ils ont raison mais
ils ont raison malheureusement qu'en
apparence alors jacques pourquoi
dites-vous en apparence évidemment
accepté d'accueillir oui si vous voulez
il ya deux problèmes
qui se pose immédiatement
premier problème c'est que on ne peut
pas toucher cosmique et ça c'est un
point important parce que jean luc
mélenchon la demie il a dit
effectivement si on augmente le smic par
exemple de 15% et bien il y aura de
toutes les manières une augmentation de
l'ensemble des bas salaires bon mais
c'est quelque chose dont ne parle ni
madame hidalgo ni monsieur fabien
roussel alors qu'est ce que ça va
représenter cet autre il ya un calcul
assez simple
l'étalement d'une hausse globale si vous
voulez sur ce qui est inférieur à la
médiane c'est à dire les 50 % les moins
bien payés des français et bien ça
pourrait représenter sur un an 17
milliards d'euros soit à peu de choses
près entre 0 7 et 0 8% du pipe ce n'est
pas du tout négligeable la deuxième le
deuxième point qui n'est jamais évoquée
c'est que ce n'est pas la première fois
que l'on parle en france d'une forte
augmentation du smic la dernière fois
qu'il ya eu une très forte augmentation
du smic c'est en 1968 ça a été
évidemment les accords de grenelle bon
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est bien pour
maintenir la compétitivité de l'économie
française le gouvernement a dû fortement
dépréciés le franc a dû faire une
dévaluation l'année suivant ça s'est
bien passé la dévaluation était
extrêmement bien maîtrisé mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas le faire
puisqu'on est dans l'euro et donc c'est
un problème si vous voulez on dit il
faut faire une espèce de rattrapage sur
les bas salaires je suis entièrement
d'accord avec eux mais ils ne disent pas
quelle est d'une certaine manière
l'implication de ce rattrapage c'est la
nécessité de déprécier fortement la
monnaie donc ça veut dire que dans un
sens vous donner raison à eric zemmour
qui lui est contre cette augmentation
est smic si vous voulez monsieur eric
zemmour est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
logique
il défend en réalité ce qui est une
version un petit peu radicaliser de la
politique que proposait à la dernière
élection présidentielle françois fillon
cette même politique dont on a vu que
quand elle a été appliquée sous nicolas
sarkozy elle avait d'ailleurs entraîné
une baisse importante des revenus moi je
me contente de dire une chose si on veut
augmenter les bas salaires et je pense
qu'il faut effectivement augmenter les
bas salaires qui a un vrai problème sur
augmentation quant à l'augmentation des
bas salaires il faut aller jusqu'au bout
de la logique est dire si on ne veut pas
détruire la compétitivité de l'économie
française il faudra déprécier la monnaie
alors donc vous pensez que la question
du pouvoir d'achat va en réalité faire
un stagiaire celle de l'euro et oui et
oui et je pense et je dois dire que
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
caractéristique de l'ensemble des
questions qui sont débattues aujourd'hui
dans cette pré campagne on n'est pas
encore dans la campagne au nez dans la
précampagne que ce soit par exemple la
question de l'immigration que ce soit la
question de la réindustrialisation
ces deux questions posent la question
pose le problème des relations par
rapport aux réglementations européennes
d'ailleurs c'est pas pour rien que
certains des candidats ou des présumés
candidats veulent organiser des
référendums sur cette question là la
question
des bas salaires eh bien ça posera la
question de l'euro et c'est peut être un
des points les plus intéressants de
cette pré campagne est bien c'est que on
va voir surgir au travers des
propositions des uns et des autres toute
une série de problèmes qu'ils ont un
problème absolument centraux de notre
relation avec l'union européenne de
notre relation avec l'euro et qu'on
verra les gens peut-être se dévoiler ou
révéler leur véritable nature à cette
occasion eh bien on verra ça risque
d'être en tout cas intéressant
subversive encore jacques d'avoir été
avec nous on parlait tout à l'heure un
toujours au chapitre économique de cette
baisse du chômage ça pourrait faire
l'objet de la prochaine édito d'ailleurs
jacques un jeu vous on lance la perche
pour jeudi prochain
le chômage qui baisse donc un baisses
records examen de bandes vante les
mérites du quoi qu'il en coûte en
entendu la milice de travail considéré
que ce choix avait permis en tout cas de
bien faire baisser le chômage on va en
parler avec pierre gardot nier garnodier
pardon secrétaire du comité national cgt
des chômeurs et des précaires bonsoir
monsieur garnodier merci d'être avec
nous il y avait marre qui se félicite
donc vous l'a félicité on joue aussi
aujourd'hui
non parce que tu as déjà le elisabeth
borgne a dit pas seulement que le
chômage il est en baisse il dit qu'on
est arrivé à un niveau qui était égal à
celui d'avant la crise or si on compare
le troisième trimestre 2000 21 par
rapport au troisième trimestre 2010 9 en
fait il ya toujours cent soixante trois
mille chômeurs de plus donc on n'est pas
du tout arriver à ce niveau
de baisse alors comment elle arrive à
parler de baisses records elle parle de
baisse record parce qu'en fait elle
parle plus du nombre de chômeurs qui
sont inscrits à pôle emploi en catégorie
à si on prend abc déjà en fait on se
rend compte qu'il ya pas une baisse qui
est si importante que ça en tout cas
c'est pas 5 5% donc c'est d'abord si
traduit c'est un basculement des
chômeurs de la catégorie a vers b c'est
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya une reprise
de l'emploi précaire justement ceux qui
seront les plus impactés par la réforme
de l'assurance chômage et puis ensuite
il y aura en quelque chose de scandaleux
au troisième trimestre 2000 21 il ya eu
100 mille radiations dans plus ou
précédent trimestre il ya cinquante
mille précaire cinquante mille chômeurs
par donc on était inscrit de force dans
des prestations qui sont totalement
bidon et donc si je fais 100 milles plus
50 milles ça fait cent cinquante mille
est la baisse du nombre de chômeurs en
catégorie à l aide de 100 millions vous
voyez on n'est pas bien loin donc invité
il ya pas vraiment de baisse du chômage
cette précarité dont on parle d'ailleurs
souvent en ce moment
la précarité elle est là elle revient
c'est ce encore une fois qu'ils sont le
plus impacté qui verront leur à louga
leur allocation baissé de 10,7 boire
jusqu'à 30 30% et pour faire le lien
avec ce que vous disiez a par avance sur
le son pouvoir d'achat il ya un million
de travailleurs pauvres un million de
travailleurs prouvant supplémentaires en
1020 par rapport à 2019 donc cette
question aujourd'hui elle est là il faut
augmenter les salaires et à la cgt nous
qu'en dit qu'il faut augmenter le
salaire pour répondre pouvoir d'achat
c'est le pouvoir d'achat tout au long de
la vie c'est dire quand on parle
d'augmentation des salaires on parle
d'augmentation du salaire direct mais
aussi indirects c'est celui qui sert à
financer l'assurance chômage c'est celui
qui sert à financer les retraites parce
que les retraités il faut augmenter leur
pension ils seront encore en lutte le 2
décembre il faut augmenter les
allocations des travailleurs qui sont
privés d'emploi des précaires nous
saurons en lutte le 4 décembre et puis
de manière générale il faut augmenter
les salaires de tous les travailleurs
parce qu'aujourd'hui de l'argent il y en
a les profits du cac 40 ils sont des
saumons en arrive à des records 50
milliards sur un semestre 2021 c'est
autant qu'en 2020 donc oui il faut
augmenter les salaires réduire peut-être
la part des cdd au profit des dc dc
c'est l'éternel débat c'est un petit peu
comme à la hausse des prix du smic on se
dit il y aura peut-être moins dans
gauche
mais axé sur la question de l' embauche
et nous c'est la justice je suis à
marseille parce que demain il y aura une
manifestation des camarades cheminots
contre la privatisation de deux ter du
train régional en paca et il y aura avec
nous les camarades de la centrale de
gardanne qui sont en lutte contre le
projet de fermeture de leur centrale
nous la cgt ce qu'on revendique c'est de
reconquérir le contrôle des embauches
c'est à dire par des nationalisations
qui sont démocratiques où ce sont les
travailleurs qui décide et du niveau de
l'emploi et de la qualité des emplois et
y a que comme ça qu'on arrivera à
contraindre le patronat a embauché
embaucher durablement il ya aussi
peut-être un espoir de ces secteurs qui
arrive pas à faire le plein l'hôtellerie
la restauration ça veut dire que
mécaniquement on va arriver cette hausse
des salaires qu'on vous appelez de vos
voeux
oui mais si je reprends encore une fois
l'exemple des des travailleurs de la
sncf des cheminots on a fait des
analyses avec la fédération il se trouve
que la sncf elle refuse d'embaucher elle
refuse d'embaucher les postes portant
sur lesquels elle s'était engagée à le
faire elle a résulté le résultat de ça
c'est quoi le résultat c'est que la sncf
elle embauche non pas en cdi puisque le
statut a été supprimée déjà mais en tout
cas lambeaux on s'est dit elle recours à
des intérimaires donc en réalité c'est
pas des autres qui sont donc pourvu cd
poste que les directions des services
publics et des entreprises du privé
refusent d'embaucher et c'est parce
qu'ils refusent d'embaucher qu'il ya un
développement de la précarité donc c'est
bien si c'est bien un signe que les
travailleurs aujourd'hui ils doivent
reconquérir ce contrôle des embauches et
le moyen et ben c'est nationaliser
démocratiquement tous les secteurs qui
sont les plus importants c'est à dire
ceux avec lesquels on peut embaucher
massivement des travailleurs privés
d'emploi alors dernière question puisque
c'était une autre annonce d'elisabeth
bande qui est lié évidemment on chômage
puisque elle a annoncé que les nouvelles
mesures de l'assurance sauvage entrerait
en vigueur le 1er décembre on imagine
que c'est une déception pour vous est-ce
qu'on c'est un combat qui est revenu
c'est pas un combat qui est perdu encore
une fois on sera en manifestation le 4
décembre avec les associations de
chômeurs le mncp là c'est la baisse le
but du jeu c'est de c'est d'arriver à
construire un mouvement de masse vous
savez dans les années 90 puis dans les
années 2000 puis dans les années 2010 il
ya des mouvements de chômeurs qui ont
réussi à imposer une réponse à l'urgence
sociale et aujourd'hui on en est là
voilà aujourd'hui on en est encore là il
ya toujours plus de chômeurs il ya deux
millions de plus de chômeurs en 2020
qu'en 1998 on s'en va voilà et donc le
gouvernement non seulement il doit
annuler sa réforme mettre en place une
vraie politique de l'emploi basée sur la
réduction du temps de travail notamment
les trades de les 32 heures ces quatre
millions d'emplois supplémentaires ces
120 milliard d'euros supplémentaires
pour notre système de protection sociale
et c'est qu'avec cette mesure là on
pourra penser une indemnisation pour
tous les travailleurs qui sont ils et
d'emploi c'est qui aujourd'hui sont
indemnisés ou merci beaucoup pierre
garnodier d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rb france
et hausse des prix de l'énergie on en
parlait il ya quelques minutes avec
jacques sapir une situation qui touche
les quatre coins du monde illustration
en équateur où les manifestations se
poursuivent contre la politique
économique du gouvernement est à
d'urgence est décrété à quito thibault
jana
des routes bloquées plus d'un millier de
manifestants dans les rues de quito pour
le deuxième jour consécutif des
opérations de protestation ont été
organisés un peu partout dans le pays
cible des opposants la politique
économique du gouvernement équatorien à
l'appel de la confédération nationale
des peuples indigènes ses actions de
blocage vise en tout premier lieu la
hausse des prix des carburants une
hausse mensuelle ajusté depuis l'année
dernière sur les prix internationaux
c'est ainsi que le prix du gallon
américain de diesel le carburant le plus
consommé en équateur a augmenté de 90%
le prix de l'essence lui est fixé à 2
dollars 55 le gallon une flambée des
prix qui nourrit la colère des
équatoriens
le peuple équatorien se soulèvent
aujourd'hui et ce n'est que le début
nous ne voulons pas déstabiliser la
démocratie ni la politique dans le pays
au contraire nous voulons qu'elle soit
renforcée
mais le gouvernement national doit
réduire le prix de l'essence s'il veut
trouver une solution dans le pays
nous ne disons pas que le gouvernement
devrait partir mais qu'il devrait
s'asseoir se remettre en question et le
faire pour le peuple équatorien pour les
paysans si la police appuyés par l'armée
s'est appliqué à dégager la plupart des
axes routiers bloqués des heures ont en
revanche éclaté lors du rassemblement
dans les rues de quito mardi en fin
d'après midi quelques dizaines de
manifestants ont lancé des pierres en
direction des policiers qui ont répliqué
avec du gaz lacrymogène
bilan selon le gouvernement 37
arrestations et cinq policiers blessés
et ce malgré l'état d'urgence décrété le
18 octobre pour lutter contre
l'insécurité une situation qui a conduit
le président équatorien guillermo olaso
à prendre la parole
j'appelle une fois de plus au dialogue
au consensus
à la réflexion sur les avantages du pays
et non sur les intérêts personnels
partisan ou syndicaux
un appel au calme et au dialogue alors
que le climat est pour le moins
explosive dans le pays la guerre des
gangs pour contrôler le marché de la
cocaïne atteint des sommets tandis que
l'économie peine à se relever surtout et
guillermo olaso le sait la confédération
nationale des peuples indigènes a déjà
contribué à renverser trois présidents
entre 1997 et 2005 et poussé l'ancien
chef d'état lenin moreno à faire marche
arrière sur la suppression totale des
subventions publiques aux carburants
au tour en france où les président et
vice président de la chambre
d'agriculture du lot-et-garonne ont été
jugés en appel aujourd'hui pour avoir
réalisé le lac de caussade malgré
l'interdiction du préfet un lac pourtant
indispensable pour les agriculteurs de
la région rt france et rendu sur place
reportage hervé grand champ avec grace
dai a
sauvé son exploitation c'est le combat
de sa vie pour mathieu martinez
agriculteurs le legs de caussade est un
allié tout trouvé pour permettre aux
exploitations locales de se développer
massivement sera permis une
diversification des exploitations écoles
et ç'a permis aussi d'atteindre un
niveau on va dire de qualité et de
quantité qui permet d'une part de
réaliser des productions ce contrat et
d'autre part de se diversifier pour pour
maintenir les exploitations en 2018
passant outre l'interdiction de l'état
et de la préfecture la chambre
d'agriculture organisent la construction
d'une retenue d'eau de 20 hectares et de
neuf cent vingt mille mètres cubes d'eau
le but est de permettre à une trentaine
d'exploitations d'irriguer des cultures
pendant les périodes sèches pour mathieu
ce lac représente un investissement
lourd qu'il ne regrette pas pour son
exploitation située à 2 km du lac cet
apport supplémentaire en eau est vital
sans cette irrigation les nouveaux
arbres fruitiers plantés aurait souffert
de la sécheresse et ne se seraient pas
bien développé devant quelques photos il
se souvient de ce chantier art normes en
regardant les photos sont ce qu on peut
évoquer c'est surtout une détermination
sans faille avec une volonté collective
et qui a permis de réaliser
un lac qui au bénéfice aussi bien des
agriculteurs que de l'environnement pour
les associations de protection de la
nature le lac est illégale et les
retenues d'eau ne sont pas une solution
désormais on attend que les pouvoirs
publics fassent respecter ses décisions
de justice que ce site soit remise en
état que le barrage soit détruit pour
repartir sur de bonnes bases et trouver
de l'eau en été on s'appuyant sur autre
chose que les retenues d'eau qui ne sont
pas les meilleures solutions pour le
président de la chambre d'agriculture
cela qui est un symbole symbole des
agriculteurs qui se battent pour leur
terre évidemment qu'ils ont besoin de
cette eau est et pas que les méchants
agriculteurs conventionnels puisque au
milieu de tout cela il ya des
agriculteurs qui sont en bio et le
département du lot-et-garonne et
significative dans ses cultures et dans
son agriculture par le fait qu'il ya une
grande quantité de culture que c'est pas
de la monoculture qu'on ne naît pas de
méchants maïsiculteurs même si nous en
avons quelques jeunes parmi nous que
nous n'utilisons pas le befoza ta aveu
tu en voilà donc et que surtout ce
ruisseau qui est à sec en été quand y'a
pas le lac ne l'est plus maintenant
puisque le lac on avait quatre cent
mille mètres cubes pour soutenir le
débit d'étiage de l'été donc il ne l'est
plus la revue la vire ville reviennent
de dames les pêcheurs nous nous nous
félicitons on revient à avoir des goûts
jaune dans le talk à angers et 2020
l'ancienne présidence de la chambre
d'agriculture serge bousquet cassagne et
patrick franquin ont été condamnés à de
lourdes peines très et 22 mois de prison
ferme pour serge ce jugement est un
attentat juridique jeudi ils seront
jugés en appel des agriculteurs du
département se mobiliseront pour les
soutenir selon les organisateurs ils
seront au moins un millier à se déplacer
avec tracteurs et engins agricoles
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous lundi
prochain à 20h en attendant l'actualité
évidemment continue toute la soirée sur
rtl france
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'uniforme
c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il y a
quand même la liberté je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
je
il a donc été contaminé par un enfant en
lui sauvant la vie
[Musique]
il m'a appelé pour la dernière fois
c'était mon anniversaire
il m'a dit maman par deux mois et c'est
un it's you
[Musique]
je sais que mon père a contracté ce
virus à l'hôpital
il a joué dit avoir transporté un
patients suspectés d'avoir le coville et
en amérique quand on dit suspecté cela
signifie qu'ils ont le coc vide elle a
aimé cette personne pendant 44 ans est
le dernier message sur what's app avait
été envoyé dix minutes avant qu'elle
aille ou soins intensifs et c'était un
message à un patient qui était malade et
à lui expliquer quels médicaments
prendre
et en tant que maire j'ai pleuré parce
qu'il aurait dû se marier ce jour là au
lieu de cela ils étaient à l'hôpital
il a dit ses derniers mots il a dit
combien il a dit
je t'aime tellement
je suis médecin moi même je comprends ce
qui m'arrive
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure de gens dont deux singes
le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages on a l'impression
qu'on descend des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés et nous sommes
cousins germains maternelle qui était
bretonne me disais si toi tu descends du
sage mois seront pas révélées nous un
secret vous en avez mangé du mammouth je
me trouve à fouiller en sibérie et puis
un beau matin dans le trou que j'avais
commencé à creuser je trouve que les
troupes comme ce quelque chose de bien
les grands filaments je suis étonnée je
râle je dirais que ce sont des collègues
russes qui sont venus tripatouiller le
fond de ma recherche et puis à force de
tirer dessus comme rien ne venait je me
suis aperçu que j'étais sur le dos tu
avais le 20 août
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer gillet jugés stratégiques et sur
ces dossiers sensibles je vais partager
avec vous mon interprétation les ong
sont devenus en 50 ans des acteurs
incontournables de la société moderne et
pour certaines de la géopolitique
mondiale par leur impact auprès des
gouvernements et du public les
politiques ne peuvent pas les ignorer et
doivent même les soutenir s'ils ne
veulent pas subir critiques et
dénonciations
s'appuyant sur des idées souvent
généreuse ou des valeurs morales elles
savent utiliser les médias et les
réseaux sociaux comme caisse de
résonance pour se positionner comme
référence dans leurs interprétations de
l'intérêt général
nombre d'entre elles apportent une
réelle contribution
pour améliorer la situation du domaine
dans lequel elles ont choisi d'exercer
d'autres ont pris une place essentielle
dans la vie des pays en distribuant des
bons et des mauvais points sur le niveau
d'adéquation des hommes des entreprises
et des états sur la base de leurs
propres critères elle couvre aujourd'hui
tous les juges en sélectionnant des
objectifs prioritaires qu'elles vont
surmédiatisé auprès du grand public
malheureusement le sectarisme de la
majorité d'entre elles les amènent à des
interprétations qui exclut toute pensée
ou comportements n'allant pas dans leur
sens et leur conviction ne respectant
pas la présomption d'innocence elles
sont relayées par des médias en quête de
boucs émissaires et de thèmes
accrocheurs
indifférent aux conséquences sociales et
économiques de leurs actes ces nouveaux
ayatollahs s'impose par la pression la
peur où l'action face à des politiques
qui rarement ont le courage de les
affronter et de rappeler les vérités ou
des évidences pourtant factuel les
populations
ayant perdu confiance dans leurs élites
se laisse facilement convaincre par ses
ong qui leur apportent un constat et des
objectifs mais
ces affirmations
d'organisation voulant aussi bien sauver
la planète
les humains ou le doryphore doré contre
les prédateurs qui établir la démocratie
dont il rêve ne correspondent
malheureusement que de loin à la réalité
il faut que ceux qui se laissent séduire
par leur rhétorique en prennent
conscience
confondant régulièrement les grands
principes avec leurs objets tif
politique ne jugeant qu'à travers le
prisme exclusive de leurs critères
n'hésitant pas à tordre les faits et à
utiliser tous les moyens pour imposer
leur vérité des ong
développent des stratégies d' influence
qui privilégie l'émotionnel sur le
rationnel il y a plus de dix ans la
fondation prometheus dans la seule étude
française fait sur le financement des
hauts revenus avait brisé le secret qui
les entourent
la triste réalité c'est que 70 % sont
financés par des états ou des
entreprises pour promouvoir de manière
subliminale
leurs objectifs et ceci explique
pourquoi il est si souvent difficile de
connaître leurs vrais décideurs ou
l'origine et les bénéficiaires des dons
qu'elles reçoivent il faut dépasser
l'apparence de leurs programmes de santé
d'éducation de lutte contre la pauvreté
de défense des droits humains ou de
protection de l'environnement pour
identifier l'objectif réel recherché
certes on n'a guère de doute sur le but
réel des ong américaine comme le
national democratic institute for
international affairs où l'international
républicaine et si tout ou encore des
quatre britannique créée par l'oligarque
russe mikhaïl khodorkovski
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour
d'autres et compris pour ceux qui
travaillent et ignore les mobiles réels
de ceux qui les emploient comme l'a
déclaré récemment le général buquet
commandant la direction du renseignement
et de la sécurité de la défense
devant nos députés si les militants
agissent en toute innocence
avec naïveté les financements
proviennent parfois de puissance qui
oeuvre contre les intérêts de la france
c'est d'autant plus regrettable que cela
jette un doute sur de véritables ong
humanitaires qui font un travail discret
mais admirable comme acte aide atd quart
monde ou emmaüs
l'analyse des actions antinucléaires de
greenpeace montrent des parti pris
intéressant dans le jeu